I really want to start with a sincere
um congrats on this uh I thought it was
fantastic thank you man thank you so
much
uh so I like throwing a curveball at the
beginning when I do interviews
um so I'm going to word this one a
little differently if someone has never
seen or heard anything that you've done
before uh what is the first thing you
want them watching or listening to and
why oh my God
I'm gonna answer first because I feel
like yours
um mine would be uh when I did love Live
season two I really loved that uh it was
really good and uh I'm also excited
about this new project of coming out um
pretty soon and I want you guys to see
that too uh called intergalactic
man
um I would I guess I would say
Intergalactic you know because this
because this is probably
um
the biggest thing I've ever done as an
artist you know just the the scale of
which this this kind of ended up being
you know it's I've just never done
anything like that you know and and uh
yeah it was a really ambitious thing and
I didn't even know if it could happen
when I first came up with the idea sort
of just see it now it's just crazy but
yeah I would say Intergalactic
considering your breath of work I'm
honored to actually be a part of that so
yeah yeah yeah man oh thank you okay
listen I I I understand why you would
say this
um it this is one of the things that's
really hard to do like you can't
quantify cool it either is or it isn't
you can't it's just you know what I mean
and this is just cool
um you know it the way it mixes music
and fashion and art and it's just like
this really cool Melting Pot can you
sort of talk about why it was important
to bring all these different things
together in this particular story well
yeah I I feel like you know these things
all the things you're talking about the
culture the the the the the art the
music all these things was something
that we haven't seen in animation you
know and I just really wanted to you
know kind of do something new and
something that people haven't done
before because I was I at this place as
an artist where I was getting bored with
the same old thing recording an album
dropping two music videos and then
that'd be it and um I just was thinking
about how could I you know do something
bigger you know and and give people a
new experience and and yeah this show
was like the perfect the perfect thing
you know for me at the time
Jessica talk a little bit about what
it's like actually because you've
obviously recorded voice for a while
what and actually for both of you what
is it like actually seeing the finished
art because it's just so much more I'm
sure than the product of what you
thought it could be yeah yeah yeah I
mean of the two of us obviously I'm the
one that's recorded voice more
um no I mean this was my honestly first
of all this is maybe the coolest thing
I've ever done like this is the first
time no this is the first time I've got
like my gen Z cousins they're like oh
what's that what's that you got going on
like a cool Auntie
um but it's I've done a lot of
podcasting this is something where we
have this interesting Dynamic where I
was just sort of following your vision
and I didn't know in the end how
anything was gonna look because it
wasn't animated so I just had to go on
what the acting was shout out to
Fletcher our director and Maurice who
like wrote it and we sort of recorded
this over a couple years
um so it was just kind of dropping in
and out of this sort of long-term
project and then I finally saw it a
couple months ago and we were talking
about how weird it is to see sort of
versions of ourselves doing [ __ ] that
we've never done before so that's
actually a very surreal and weird
experience yeah it was it was for me
like because I I over time was seeing
bits and pieces and stuff like that so I
was kind of like the the the finished
product was kind of forming in my mind
over time throughout the three years but
um
there was something about seeing it
finished like when we watched the
screening a couple months ago
and just like
just seeing it completed and then like
at the end just crying like I was
weeping like and it's not oh it was it
was like happy tears because I was like
oh my God number one it worked dear God
and number two and number two this is a
really sweet story you know like this is
a this is a really sweet love story that
I feel like everybody's going to connect
to it's it's it's just so real and and
and uh one thing that Vanessa said
actually she said you almost forget that
you're watching animation you know uh
because it's just such such uh such an
emotional ride you're on you know I I
completely agree I I'm just about out of
time so an individual question for each
of you guys
um Scott I'm so curious about Teddy
because this is obviously a huge thing
that you're working on you know I'm what
can you tease people about it and uh
Jessica talk a little bit about getting
to possibly work I don't know if you did
with Harrison Ford because
um that's that's a whole nother thing
yeah I just finished um do you want
alcohol I just finished I just finished
this apple show with Jason Siegel and
Harrison Ford uh and I'm just so excited
about it it'll come out in a few months
I I mean that guy he is like the first
few weeks of filming I had to get used
to his face because sometimes we would
do takes and I'd be like holy [ __ ]
that's Han Solo like I'm Greedo right
now like I'm like holy [ __ ] and then
sometimes
sometimes it's like is this Indiana
Jones and it's like wow he kind of he's
like doing the face but then also he
really cares about the work and he's
really like
he's just good and like sometimes he'll
just have these like really incredible
magic takes and he's just amazing to
watch he's like the guy and um he has a
great sense of humor and he like rides
his bike around and is just lovely and
sweet and he's like he just really cares
about doing a good job and he's kind and
so I really I like that I like that man
I like that man a lot he looks like he
would be that awesome yeah he's just
he's just great and he always like he's
like got a glint in his eye because he's
pretty mischievous yeah you know like
he's like talk some [ __ ] you know
sometimes and he's just he's just cool
he's also just cool he's got that old
man I don't give a fuckness yes 100 and
you can see that throughout you know his
career he's like oh there's a little bit
of that but then he does care about the
work so it's like it was a joy I can't
wait for you guys to see it it's really
funny
um
awesome yeah I'm so jealous
um
um
so Teddy uh Teddy is is coming together
um we're still hoping to do it at
Netflix uh we have a script the script
is is done uh I feel really really I
feel really good about it
um we've been reaching out to some
people that we want to cast in It seeing
availability
um hopefully we shoot it next year
sometime
so uh yeah that's happening but um
there's some other things going on too
that I'll be talking about in the next
couple months so don't worry more more
[ __ ] more action
uh sincerely congratulations thank you
so much for your time thank you so much
we appreciate it